it was pretty funny because I got a lot
of flack for making my little joke about
the slacktivism earlier in the day with
the rainbow on the black square I got so
much flak all these white liberals were
very upset with me but then by the end
of the day I actually was looking pretty
good because I was making fun of the
black squares and all the black lives
matter people then started making fun of
the black squares and so all the white
liberals felt really embarrassed that
they posted the black squares and they
felt sort of like they can't win for
losing this happened with a Hermione
Granger what is her name Emma Watson
Emma Watson who is woke man this chicky
is far-left
she's started the he for she campaign
radical feminist really big on all these
kind of racial identity politics so she
posts the squares the black square but
she did it it had like a special border
or something or she did it multiple
times so that her Instagram feed which
has a zillion followers you know she's
big celebrity she wanted her Instagram
feed to look look nice well showing
support for BLM savaged her they savaged
her because well one cuz it was just
slacktivism but because she was taking
so much care for herself you know is so
much just about her and you saw so many
people all these blue checkmarks on
Twitter they would say look you it's you
got to do more than just post the square
you've got a donate you've been donating
I donated to this group I have liberal
friends of mine who are screenshotting
their donations to various bail funds
for probably for an Tifa actually but
they think it's going to to black
protesters and I reposted one of these
people and I said you know you're doing
all of these things but most importantly
you're posting on social media about it
you're showing everybody to a great
person you are because you're virtuous
and you're very living
[Music]
[Music]